Tom starts us off this hour in New
Hampshire hey Tom how are you I'm good
Dave how are you better than I deserve
what's up in your world
I got a retirement uestion for you I am
a shop teacher of 42 years and I'm
approaching retirement and trying to
figure out when the best time to retire
is at the end of next year I will be at
the full retirement age for Social
Security and also my retirement pension
plan and my retirement plus Social
Security will equal what I make as a
regular paycheck Wow they say it doesn't
pay to keep working but the thing that I
keep thinking about is every year I
worked obviously my tension return and
my Social Security will continue to go
up and so will the cost of living I
retire right away then that's a no lots
in my income at that point I also have a
remodeling business that I do in the
summer that brings in a fair amount of
money so I if I retire I could do that
more but I am going to be 66 by then so
I don't know how much longer I can do
remodeling but all those factors
together trying to figure out what's the
best mix or when I should switch you
know my grandpa was an accountant at
Alcoa aluminum and he retired at I
believe was 65 years old and he really
enjoyed being a general contractor for
the rest of his life that's what he
wanted to do his whole life and he took
the accounting job because jobs were
scarce in the great depression and he
was happy to have one but but but you
know it occurs to me that a shop teacher
would make an excellent general
contractor meaning you could teach and
run subs and not have to swing the
hammer yourself I got a friend that's
running I got a friend he's not he's not
66 he's not like you and me he's not in
his 60s but but he's in his 40s but he
made 300 grand last your profit on his
remodeling business and he's a GC he
just ran subs he didn't swing a hammer
all right I've thought about that it's
just
a lot to keeping things running in the
background um like this time of year I'm
doing estimates so I'm up late a lot of
times at night doing that yeah you could
you could run your own estimates run
your own paperwork run the jobs but you
don't swing a hammer which which my case
my point is is 66 you don't necessarily
want to swing a hammer to me up on 425
feet in here with a paintbrush in your
hand or something I don't want to be and
so but you know but you can have a lot
of fun and make more than you make now
doing that and still you know just in
other words you decide which of the
activities you want to do don't want to
do how big you want it to be or how big
you don't want to be you decide this is
your business but I think your summer
gig is a real opportunity and you take
full pay from the other gig that you've
worked at your whole life - you know -
you eat off of that and then any money
you make on the remodeling just gravy on
the biscuit right yeah well I I've been
doing that because I love teaching I
still enjoy it I think you could teach a
lot of young guys to trade while they're
being your sub oh yeah yeah well I mean
yeah and my point is is that a good GC
is not just standing back balsan people
they're teaching and leading the project
the job through the through them thing
and you've got a lot of experience doing
that I just think it's I think you'd
have a lot of fun doing it it sounds to
me like you do what you want to do if I
woke up in your shoes it's how I answer
questions around here
retirement for me does not mean sit on
my butt play golf six days a week and
fish the other three you know or
whatever I did doesn't what it means to
me and what it means to me is I'm gonna
do what I want to do which I started
doing about 20 years ago doing what I
want to do so you oughta go do what you
want to do but it sounds like that would
be fun for you oh and by the way it
makes a lot of sense financially too so
that's a neat one-two punch you know
what you want to I just I think you've
been comfortable with the steadiness of
the teaching and the idea of running
your own business scares you a little
bit which is probably good for your soul
at 66 it's good to be scared ever so
often get out there and do something man
hey I think you can do it